in those systems therefore which are
characterized by a fixed general self
sameness this means that both the
cognitive side and the things themselves
remain self same but this expansion of
the self identical determinate pneus
each of which describes the course of
its progress unhindered and with scope
for free play leads of necessity equally
to its opposite to the confusion of
these determinants nas's for the
differentiate the general characteristic
is the unity of opposites of what is
determinate and what is in itself
universal it must therefore split up it
into this antithesis if now on the one
side the determinate pneus gains the
ascendancy over the universal in which
it has its essence on the other side
again this Universal equally maintains
its control over that determinate pneus
pushes it to its boundary and their
mixes up its distinctions and essential
ities observation which kept them
properly apart and believed that in them
it had something from and settled sees
principles overlapping one another
transitions and confusions developing
what it at first took to be absolutely
separate it sees combined with something
else and what it reckoned to be in
combination it sees apart and separate
so it is that observation which clings
to passive unbroken self same in
disappearing inevitably sees itself
tormented just in its most general
determinations for example of what are
the differentiate animal or a plant by
instances which robit of every
determination invalidate the
universality to which it had risen and
reduce it to an observation and
description which is devoid of thought
in paragraph 247 we're now going to take
a closer look at the differentiate or
rather we're going to look at a certain
perspective that uses the differential
to try to make sense of things which is
what reason wants to do and let's remind
ourselves a little bit before we go into
this paragraph the paragraphs to follow
about what is going on here so we're in
this section reason reason has
everything for it in an implicit way so
that means that the rationality or
intelligibility that reason is is
finding is out there and things it's
observing reason right and so it's
observing nature it's observing the the
world in which it finds itself and it is
finding some sort of intelligibility or
rationality out there because it's
already there for consciousness so
there's a correspondence between the
world outside of the the ego the
individual the consciousness and the
consciousness itself now this
correspondence is one that is
continually disrupted by the process of
actually looking at things and finding
out no I've got them wrong and in
certain respects they need to be revised
what I'm thinking about or making of of
these things now the differential as we
saw in the previous paragraph played an
incredibly important role in making
sense out of things why is that well we
can tell what things are in part by
distinguishing them from from other
things and what we're going to see here
is angle is going to examine how that
works out when we try to assume you
might say a universe of fixed essences
that we just have to go out there and
discover essences which would be
separated from each other which we could
find in individual things and the you
know the sort of dream or goal of
certain ancient
and this runs all the way through to
contemporary ways of looking at things
it is of setting up some things sort of
like a tree where you have being as such
at the top and then you start going down
into geniuses or regions of being if you
prefer that language and then we you
know we get more and more differentiated
as we get further down so you know
beating animate being maybe that's
doesn't doesn't deserve to be a top cat
or at all but let's just assume it does
animate being rational animate be a
right human be a because maybe there's
other rational am at the eggs you know
and we can go further and further down
and then the things that differentiate
want to keep them distinct from other
things in that tree process Hagel is
going to show us that when we rely on
that sort of thing we often end up in
difficulties and perplexities in trouble
so he says in systems which are
characterized by a fixed general self
sameness right where we assume that they
just are what they are the law of
identity as we normally think about it
applies all across the board there's no
dynamism things don't develop right in
these systems we can assume a kind of
correspondence between the cognitive
side what Miller's translating is
cognitive side is in German air cannon
or sometimes translated as cognition
right this means the cognitive side and
the things themselves remain self same
so we actually have three things that
are remaining so saying we have what is
holding them together these these
systems we have the things themselves
presumably out there in the world we
have our own conception of them and
since the things themselves are
remaining self saying our conception of
them should remain so same or if we want
to go the other way so it's our
conception of them is as being self
saying the things themselves had better
remain self safe now that's all great
unless things don't remain self same
and as we know within the Hegelian
viewpoint on things nothing ever remains
something the self-same actually repels
itself from itself and is attracted in
some way to what is other to that right
so when we see this you know being
framed in this way it's just like when
we see Hagel use the word immediate we
should know hey there's going to be some
reversal coming up so let's watch and
see what that is so hey Neil says this
expansion of the self identical
determinate nas's each of which
describes a course of its progress
unhindered and with school for free play
notice that it's developing and there
has to be some sort of lack of hindrance
there has to be some free play leads of
necessity to its opposite to the
confusion of these determinate nas's
what are the determinants is that he's
talking about the systems and then these
you know not component parts but rather
what we might call perspectives both of
which by the way are in consciousness
consciousness out in the world
consciousness observing the world right
so how does this play out he says the
differentia the general characteristic
is the unity of opposites what is
determinate and what is in itself
universal it must therefore split up
into this antithesis okay so what what
is he talking about there well sort of
like when we talked very early on in the
consciousness section about how
universal is actually work and we said
you know there's a bit more
paradoxically to universals because they
are the things that they are and they're
also not what they are and they also
make the things that they are the
universal of the things that they are
and yet wouldn't exist as univer that we
can go out and on and on right so same
sort of thing is happening here the
determinant pneus of what is being
differentiated is one side and the
universality
is another side so you know let's use
some prosaic examples right I should
have brought more ties out here so I can
do this so gotta tie that I'm wearing
you just have to remember other ties
that I've worn in my videos and imagine
other ties that you might be wearing so
on and so forth right there's a
universality to this and we can talk in
terms of ties in general so if you say
in a very pragmatic way you say I need
to go buy a tie you don't necessarily
think blue tie with white dots in the
middle in a square pattern or anything
necessarily yeah that let's determine it
right or at least we think that it's
determining this will get there in a
minute so universally universality for
ty not only includes this time with this
pattern it also includes blue striped
ties it also includes red striped ties
it also includes red solid ties it also
includes black ties and and so on and so
forth right the tie writ large and timer
that large doesn't actually have the
determinate pneus of having color tie
writ large isn't necessarily made out of
whatever this is made out of probably
one is it so there we go some of my
times are made some others I think are
made of other things I don't really know
because I'm not a person who cares much
about a time I'm more interested in the
universal than I am them to determine in
this now let us think a little bit more
about this determinant is so we said
that this ty has certain properties that
as determinants set it apart from the
universal ty to give it determinist
being right like being blue being made
of silk having this pattern being of a
certain length you can tell exactly how
long it is by looking at how much ty
there is and going on from there that
said that determinate this is a
different she isn't it because it's
is it apart from other ties so with in
the universal which is part of what is
being you know determined out here this
whole play takes place again at further
and further and further levels depending
on what we're actually looking at Hagel
notes that we have a similar problem
here we're not dealing with artifacts at
this point we're thinking in terms of
say animals plants physical phenomena he
says if on the one side the determinate
miss gains the ascendancy over the
universal in which it has its essence on
the other side of the universal people
equally maintains its control over that
determinant this pushes it to its
boundary their mixes up its distinctions
and essentiality so these exist in a
dynamic tension with each other known in
terminus well then you get no universal
right because you don't have to get a
versal if you don't have some things
that that Universal is the universal for
on the other hand determining this by
itself doesn't mean anything without
having the universal that provides a
kind of index for it and they both kind
of war or struggle or conflict with each
other both of them would like to be the
whole thing for consciousness both of
them are sort of striving with each
other within the thing itself for Hadel
what does this lead to he says
observation wants to keep them strictly
apart right wants to differentiate
between the terminus and universality
what happens that he says it believed in
them and he had something firm and suck
right you can say okay here's the
universal here's the various determinate
pneus right we keep everything the same
he goes on i says it sees principles
overlapping one another this is what
I've tried to pick down here right I'm
not saying this is a very good iconic
representation of principles overlapping
each other but
and how you're possibly going to put
that out to a chalkboard you have to
think here this is this sort of
conceptual thinking as opposed to
representative for Stella thinking
principles are overlapping each other
right transitions and confusions
developing what it took it first to be
absolutely separated seas combined with
something else what it reckoned to be in
combination it sees apart and separate
this is part of the dialectical process
there's a dynamism there and that
dynamism doesn't just extend to say the
things themselves is growing and all
that it has to do even with these sort
of categories or if you like you know
logical divisions or however you want to
think about it it has to do with the
very nature of being itself and so
observing reason reason observing nature
finds out that when it assumes this
fixed self sameness there that doesn't
actually hold up so he goes on and he
says it's see the observation which
clings to passive unbroken cell say
madness of being and equitably sees
itself tormented just in its most
general determinations for example what
are the different she I animal or a
plant by instances which Robin of every
determination invalidate the
universality to which it had risen and
reduce it to an observation and
description which is devoid of thought
remember back just several paragraphs
before we had this activity of
description which we saw a Hagel calling
thoughtless or you know unthinking right
gedanken was it was it was the germ of
the german court and that is the risk
you know what we would fall into that
would be able to aggression instead what
we're going to see the paragraphs to
come is a rethinking of what is going on
here and maybe looking at what's the
problem this assumption of fixed general
determinations that just stay the same
observation which confines itself in
this way to what is simple or restrains
the scattered sensuous elements by the
universal thus finds in its object the
confusion of its principle because what
is determinate must through its own
nature lose itself in its opposite
reason must therefore move on from the
inert determinate pneus which had a show
of permanence to observing it as it is
in truth that is as relating itself to
its opposite what are called diferencia
are passive determinate nas's which when
it expressed an apprehensive apprehended
is simple do not represent their nature
which is to be vanishing moments of a
movement which returns back into itself
since reason now reaches the stage of
looking for the determinate pneus as
something which essentially is not for
itself but which passes over into its
opposite it seeks for the law and the
notion of the determinate pneus true it
seeks for them equally as an actuality
in the form of immediate being but this
will in fact vanish for it and the
aspects of the law become pure moments
or abstraction so that the law that
comes to light in the nature of the
notion which is destroyed within itself
the indifferent subsistence of sensuous
reality
in the previous paragraph we saw
observing reason getting itself
embroiled and you might say embarrassed
by its failure to understand the beings
that it's attempting to make sense of
and as Hagel said you know whining and
it sort of a mess of overlapping
principles and determinations all of
which were supposed to be distinct from
each other differentiated from each
other and the problem was that it didn't
take account of the dynamic movement
within these things that it's trying to
make sense of and consciousness is own
role here in paragraph 248 we're going
to see the beginnings of that and it's
going to lead us into some very
interesting new steps that Hagel wants
to unroll from this so we have to
imagine ourselves you know in the role
of consciousness at the beginning of
this movement of reasons very optimistic
and then suddenly being through dismayed
now what what comes after that reason
wants to find the solution so Hagel
talks and I sort of adumbrated this this
sentence right here you know what is
determinant must lose itself in its
opposite he actually says instead of
that short thing he says that what is
determinate must true its own nature
lose itself in its opposite yeah
observation finds its in its object the
confusion of its principal right the
principle of trying to make sense of
things trying to differentiate things
differentiating means holding things
apart in an opposition so if you're
losing yourself in your opposite or
becoming as Hagel is calling it here is
he's called it so many other times
something becoming a vanishing moment
you're not accomplishing them so how
might you then make some sort of
progress okay so we've got the progress
sort of charted here on the board he
says officer
beishin that can finds itself in this
way to what is simple or restrains the
scattered sensuous elements by the
universal it's going to run into these
problems it must move on from the inert
determinate nest which had a show of
permanence right so what do we got here
is this is that first starting point
observation that's part of what reason
is doing is observing the simple inert
sensu sensuous determinate pneus right
as their use of multiple things and
trying to make sense of them now what is
it really observing in this case what we
saw I in the last two paragraphs is it's
really observing the differential and
these differential are being themselves
understood as passive but also as
determinate pneus and we saw that
there's this play between determinate us
and the universal involved there as well
but this is not working out for it why
not well that because we pass over to
the the next step which is passing over
into its opposite both in terms of the
differentiate they have this internal
contradiction in which both parts are
passing over into each other and when we
try to make sense of the differentiate
as a tool in order to really distinguish
things from each other we find that we
get this overlapping network of stuff
instead instead of a nice handy tree
right so he says I'm since reason now
reaches the stage of looking for the
determinate pneus as something which is
essentially which essentially is not for
itself right it's not for itself it is
for and other and what is its other if
the other is the pandas is the old
consciousness and the other than that
it's passing over into its opposite
right so what does he say reason is not
going to just watch this and say oh you
know things didn't work out maybe I
should go back to the earlier stages of
Stoicism and skepticism of the
master-slave ballot no reason doesn't do
that reason says I think I can figure
this out and remember what does reason
seeking
this really receiving the truth of the
phenomena so what is going to do is
strive for grasping as Hagel says the
law and the notion of the determinate
pneus now if speaking of the cingulate
cingular here but we can pick whatever
determinate Ness we want because he's
talking about trying to do this with
things in the world that we're trying to
observe and make sense so he says it
seeks for the law and the notion of the
determinists true it seeks for them
equally as an actuality in the form of
immediate being okay so there there's a
little concession right at this thing
that's it's not quite conceptualized
just how hard this is going to be but
this will in fact vanish for it and the
aspects of the law become pure moments
or abstractions so the law comes to
light yes the nature of the notion which
is destroyed within itself the
indifferent subsistence of sensuous
reality now notice sensuous reality is
what we started with over here the
differentiator already getting us away
from sensuous reality into things that
we could you know say we're talking
about determine in terms of concepts or
notions right ideas and things that we
could regularize or provide a kind of
underlying intelligibility to that's
what law is and that takes us out of the
directly pure sensuous world doesn't it
it introduces something else notice that
what we're going to be seeing here is
much of the same territory that we have
traversed earlier in the consciousness
section particularly in the paragraphs
to come in the force and the
understanding section so this is a very
important transition that's taking place
here from reason trying to engage in
observation thinking that things are
just going to kind of hold still to
realizing it needs a much wider net the
net that's going to be provided by law
to the observing consciousness the truth
of the law is found in experience in the
same way that sensuous being is an
object for consciousness is not in and
for itself but if the law does not have
its truth in the notion it is a
contingency not a necessity not in fact
along but the fact that it is
essentially in the form of notion not
only does not conflict with its being
accessible to observation but rather for
that very reason gives it a necessary
existence and makes it an object for
observation the universal in the sense
of the universality of reason is also
Universal in the sense implied in the
above notion that is it is that it is
for consciousness that it displays
itself as something present in actual in
other words the notion displays itself
in the form of thing hood and sensuous
being but it is not on that account lose
its nature nor relapse into an inert
subsistence or an indifferent succession
what is universally valid is also
universally effective what ought to be
in fact also is and what only ought to
be without actually being has no truth
the instinctive reason for its part
rightly holds firmly to this standpoint
and refuses to be led astray by figments
of thought which only ought to be and as
thoughts are credited with truth
although they are nowhere met with
inexperienced or by hypothesis as little
as by all the other invisible entities
of a perennial ought for reason is just
a certainty of possessing reality and
what is not present for consciousness is
something existing in its own right that
is what does not appear is for
consciousness nothing at all
in paragraph 249 this this idea of law
is really central we saw in 248 that
reason is going to get away from just
engaging with sort of willy nilly
observation and trying to parse out
everything in terms of the differentiate
by looking to the conception of law and
we saw that that law has to be connected
with notion in some way and Hagel is
actually parsing that out here in this
paragraph he is also going to say some
things that are really fascinating and a
much wider import than just the
progression that's going on in this
paragraph towards the Edit part of the
paragraph and that is what we got over
here he's going to say that these
insights are something that you know
observing reason in its early stages in
it's instinctual activity is you might
say assuming without actually putting
into explicit form what much later is
going to put these into an explicit form
so let's see what what's actually being
said here he says we've got to pull
areas right we've got the the truth of
the law being found in experience with
the sensuous particulars the determinate
nas's is what Hagel's using here and
we've got here is sensuous being and
this is a realm of contingency and the
act is what law must actually bear upon
if it's going to be a lot at all because
otherwise what the hell is it about is
it just about you know pure abstract
objects that would be fine for saying
mathematical laws right but we're
interested in observing nature the
things that we're encountering those are
contingent those are sensuous we have to
experience those and so if a law can't
tell us something about those then what
the hell good isn't hey on the other
hand if it's going to be a law we have
them this side of the notion of the
universal
of necessity because like higgles going
to say here here we go if the law does
not have its truth in the notion it is a
contingency not a necessity not in fact
a lot so the fundamental question that
we're asking here it's a trick question
because there's two answers to it that
immutably had play chairs where is the
truth of the law where does it reside
does it reside solely in the necessity
if that was the case we would have to
leave this part out and then the law
wouldn't actually have the application
and we've already seen that dialectic
play out in forcing the understanding
heavenly on the other hand if we focused
on this and said well we actually do
have to experience the truth of the law
and we lose sight of this part up here
the universal the notion we lose the
very character of a law you see how
there's this you know sort of hard
kernel of things actually it's more like
a knot tied together where although we'd
like to you know have just one portion
or the other portion we got to take the
whole package and if we don't we're
going to lose law and that is what
consciousness observing is actually
putting out so he says the truth of the
was found an experience in the same way
the sensuous being is an object for
consciousness it is it is not an inning
for itself right but as a lot as name
its truth of an ocean that's a problem
so he goes out and he says the universal
in the sense of the universality of
reason is also universal in the sense
apply to the above notion that it is for
consciousness that it displays itself as
something present an actual how does it
do that
it displays itself as something present
in actual by existing in the world in
the world of sensibility experience
contingency as a universal you might say
it erupts into the world and provides it
a kind of structure if we want to be
very phenomenological and not a galley a
bit more height a gariand sense with
that so he goes on he says in other
words the notion displays itself in the
form of thing hood and sensuous being so
there's a direct connection between the
notion and sensuous being this is not an
abstraction out there just in our
consciousness we're finding the notion
there in the world in the things now he
says it does not on that count lose its
nature nor relapse into an inert
substance or indifferent succession
rather what we should think about it is
doing is as notion as universal in the
Galleon sense bringing a kind of
dynamism that the sensuous being by
itself with lack and lacking which would
only be in inert substance which
couldn't really be made sense of law is
involving both of these two polarities
but where the real emphasis is here in
this paragraph is on how the notion
itself is grasped in experience in a way
that is not reducible the sensibility
but does involve Sensibility so he goes
anatomy says what is universally valid
is also universally effective but ought
to be in fact also is what only want to
be without actually being has no true
that's why i put here on the board and
you might say well that's kind of a huge
metaphysical digression isn't it well
it's actually illustrating what we're
talking about here so let's look at this
paragraph anonymous look
the application there's a play on words
to that I want to single so that's like
with the German what is universally
valid is universally effective so what
is unit what is automatic gauteng right
is University effective Galton these are
both coming from the same route right
and so go take Gallatin these are these
are both having to do with sort of like
acceptability galaxies is you know
coming from the terminal gal that's gold
money is involved there but it's being
used in a more abstract sense of being
something that is passable something
that he's trying to build is translating
gears is effective we could say
something that that can work right
something is workable we say so what is
universally valid what what has the kind
of capacity to demand our ascent as
consciousness and saying yeah okay that
that really is the way things are it is
also something that has a kind of
activity or agency to it it can get
things done what want to be signs all in
fact also is is in there tough isn't an
actual is in action we could say what
only want to be without being has no
truth this is a pretty far-reaching
doctrine here isn't it and it could be
taken a lot of different ways some
people have mistakenly taken Hagel when
he's talking about this sort of thing to
be like the ultimate conformist to be
saying yeah I forget idealism all
together in the sense of like thinking
things could possibly ever be any
different than they are you know in
order to say something like that you
have to totally misunderstand hey gonna
ignore almost everything else that he
says a lot of people have taken in that
sense how should we understand it here
in order for the notion that is one side
of the law to
actually the effective or valid it has
to be out there in the things and be
able to be you might say seen or sensed
by us not purely reducible to that but
it has to be out there doing something
so people says consciousness actually
graphs all of this he says the
instinctive reason rightly holds firmly
to this standpoint that says look if
it's if it doesn't have any real you
know effective being let's not talk
about it let's not pretend that it
actually matters he says it refuses to
be led astray by figments of thought
which only want to be and as odds are
credited with truth though there are no
where met with and experience think
about how many things that people talk
about and even may think are you know
sort of stand-ins for whatever science
means to them and when you get down to
it they can't they really they can't
tell you much about them other than
repeating themselves or repeating what
they read and you know some some popular
science review or websites and they
can't tell you where they meet with it
an experience in any real way they can
say well I use this to interpret what's
happening there's a lot of things in our
time in hegel's time in previous times
that are like that and you might say
that observing reason is very hard-nosed
it's saying look don't bother me with
your nonsense if you can't show me where
the hell it actually is it doesn't have
to be reducible to the sensuous but it
sure must be met with somewhere in it or
else don't try and tell me all about
this the egos anime says reason is this
certainty of possessing reality what is
not present for
something existing in its own right that
is what does not appear is for
consciousness nothing at all nothing at
all at this stage of the game we should
say this is a major realization and it's
going to affect the way in which law is
now reinterpreted in the passages yet to
come